trois jours trois jours après avoir
qualifié de terroriste l'organisation
demandé la madame thatcher a reçu
aujourd'hui à londres chez elle au 10
downing street
le vice président de l' insee climat
antenne de londres christian mary mono
produit
il a accepté de rencontrer madame
thatcher l'entretien le plus délicat de
son périple car contrairement au souhait
du vice-président de la mc lane cette
chaire a levé les sanctions contre
l'afrique du sud après sa libération
un séjour marqué par quelques accrocs
ses propos concernant l'irak et la
nécessité de négocier avec cette
organisation a crispé la classe
politique britannique
ensuite devant les hommes d'affaires il
leur a parlé de possibilités de
nationalisation et patron anglais au
français les sourcils la grande bretagne
est le premier pays investisseur en
afrique du sud
ces 48 heures se sont déroulés et
discrètement sans fanfare ni grand
meeting
si les positions entre eux mêmes cette
chaire nelson mandela sont restés
inchangés
il s'est dégagé néanmoins une volonté de
dialogue le temps fera peut-être le
reste je repars avec l'impression très
clair que le premier ministre est prête
à discuter avec nous de l'évolution des
événements en afrique du sud il s'en
passer c'est un homme fatigué mais plus
confiants qu'ils quittent londres
mettant un terme à une tournée mondiale
de deux mois avec toujours la même
obsession la fin de l'apartheid